hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
once again we are looking for
free-to-play games on ps4
this is our sixth episode in fact I've
tried to pick a varied bunch of titles
but if there's nothing on this list that
you want to play then try our other 5
episodes with another 50 games to play
almost all the games on this list are
better played with other people so pop
your PSN below and find like-minded
gamers to team up with so if you're
ready let's do this
thankfully vault-tec has manufactured
the top-of-the-line underground shelter
to protect our friends and neighbors if
you were watching Bethesda's conference
at e3 you'll know that finally after
three years of waiting fallout shelter
is available on ps4 just in case you've
been living under a rock in fallout
shelter you'll be living under a rock
you take control of your very own vault
as obviously you make all decisions
whilst you're captive audience is living
in your vault during a nuclear
bombardment outside you'll be
micromanaging every dweller giving them
jobs some menial some more advanced and
you'll even play a part in them
motivating them to earn you know
increase the population oh and it's even
possible for piper from fallout 4 to
join your merry vault how cool is that
fallout shelter has over 100 million
players completely addicted so we want
this may take over your life that's how
we build a brighter future together
underground
fallout shelter play for free now we
can't have a free games list without a
battle royale title enter h1z1 battle
royale after only being out a month it
already has 10 million players murdering
each other it's the usual premise 100
people parachute towards an island and
fight to the death
h1z1 battle royale is customizable as
you unlock visual items such as clothing
and skins for weaponry as I'm writing
this ps4 players have just been given a
new parachute and Jeep skin for free and
if you have PS plus there's even more
goodies to download without cost h1z1
battle royale is constantly improving
such as recent changes to controls and
the new revive mechanic in jewels and
squads I have a beginners guide our
future content updates on the channel so
if you haven't tried it yet have a peek
at those to get a solid footing before
jumping into battle there's talk of the
Zombie Survival original version of h1z1
known as just survive making an
appearance on ps4 later in the year but
I'll cover that when and if more
information becomes available did you
ever play the impeccable life is strange
it was an episodic adventure kinda like
the telltale games with life is strange
too coming later in 2018 a free-to-play
spinoff has arrived the awesome
Adventures of Captain Spirit the plot
follows Chris Erickson a young boy who
creates a superhero alter ego captain
spirit to deal with the loss of his
mother you're drinking beer I don't need
a lecture from my son I always get
picked last for a team at school and
they never throw the ball to me they
can't tell stories like you can can they
no way games like this rely on the
player caring for the protagonist
and having an emotional connection the
way you play this game will have a
knock-on effect to life is strange
so the awesome Adventures of Captain
spirit is a must play for fans of the
series Game Informer absolutely adored
this giving it 8.5 out of 10 gonna try
it and the slow smile me too
nobody's free next is don't bite me bro
as I'm writing this it's only available
in North America but the rest of the
world should be getting it very soon I
personally made an account for North
America and Japan
just in case these scenarios ever pop up
don't bite me bro is an open world
zombie apocalypse game with local co-op
for up to four players explore the world
for resources to build and upgrade your
shelter then defend it from the constant
waves of zombies
you'll be locating and saving survivors
to unlock them as playable characters
which have unique skills and abilities
don't bite me bro uses random level
generation so each game should feel
unique next we have the exiled realm of
our boria or terror for short this is
yet another MMORPG so if you are looking
for quests they are here in abundance
your character can be customized as
you'd expect with seven races to choose
from each having different skill sets
and attributes in battle on top of that
there are 11 classes to choose from with
another two the Valkyrie and the ninja
arriving imminently speaking of things
coming soon Terra's most explosive class
the gunner has now arrived on ps4 as yet
another free update the gunner wields a
powerful arc cannon in battle and comes
equipped with deployable combat
constructs including a turret to cover
your back and a robot that heals allies
as each skill is unlocked your character
can unleash different attacks but it's
not all about offense evading enemy's
attacks is just as important and it's
even possible to parry your fault
weapons if you want to hack and slash
your way through all these enemies it is
an option but there's more depth to the
fighting mechanics if you want there to
be Terra's content is totally free to
play from character creation all the way
to level 65 and beyond if you're looking
for a super simple game to play
then there's minefield if whoever used a
PC at school you've probably wasted many
hours on this title there's no real
difference to the ps4 version try to
find the mines without making them
explode rinse and repeat
probably there isn't a lot of love for
this one so let's move on next we have
an update to rec room a PSP our title
that's completely free I've already
talked about the game in a previous
video basically it's a
bucketload of social minigames ranging
from paintballing to sharat's I have rec
room on the list again due to the battle
royale mode which has been added it's
completely in its infancy but I can't
put into words how great it feels to
play battle royale in VR it's
ridiculously fun and bloody
nerve-racking for some reason rec room
doesn't support 100 players instead it
opts for 15 players on a smaller map
aiming is much harder than on controller
or keyboard and mouse as you'll need the
Move controllers to play I know it
doesn't look fantastic and the graphical
fidelity may throw a few people off but
believe me rec room and rec royal are
bloody great pastimes and they're free
and if you have psvr
you gotta have a go rec royale is
available right now oh and it's
cross-platform so you can play against
people on the oculus rift which is
pretty damn cool the first time I ever
saw Tec that was a kid and I thought it
was the coolest thing in the world the
big gun
the roar attention it was love at first
sight
armored warfare is a free-to-play
military MMO which allows players to
take control of cutting-edge technology
team up with your friends to tackle
challenging co-op missions and once
you're ready take the fight online and
scrap it out on the PvP battlefield
alternatively navigate across huge
interactive maps avoid surveillance
drones and airstrikes in a mix of
competitive and cooperative gameplay as
you build towards becoming a global
leader there's five main classes of tank
to utilize the main battle tank offers a
tough outer shell and powerful
explosives whereas the light tank
sacrifices armor for speed tank
destroyers are built for covert
bombardments and the armored fighting
vehicles are the scouts of the
battlefield
finally the self-propelled guns are the
only tanks in the game to be able to
fire beyond their own viewpoint it's
essentially the same game as World of
Tanks so if you like that you'll likely
enjoy armored warfare well that could
have gone better look we've all lost
dearly ok so this next one you're going
to think I've lost my marbles but stick
with me on this one battle born battle
born is a first-person shooter within a
battle arena we tend to call them hero
shooters it arrived at the same time as
overwatch so you can guess what happened
to battle born battle born has attempted
to make the game more rewarding to new
players but the enjoyment is really felt
once you've mastered aspects of fighting
the real reason I put this on the list
though is due to the connections to
Borderlands and the Easter eggs and
theories which are hidden in each level
if you're desperately waiting for
Borderlands 3 I think you'd enjoy battle
born as it builds on the fighting
mechanics created in Borderlands 1 & 2
the story mode of the game is locked
behind a paywall but the player versus
player portion is completely free that's
the section which feels most like
overwatch and paladin's the 30 heroes
are rotated on a weekly basis this is
most likely there to allow us to sample
everyone but will need to shell over
money for the full game to unlock all
characters at the same time it isn't a
cash grab but we all need to be vigilant
at the same time
it's time to be the badasses you were
born to be live together or die alone
finally yet another game that has
already been on the list twice in fact
warframe it's here again though due to
yet another expansion which once again
pushes the free-to-play title towards
epicness this is the sacrifice no call
to wake you but the sacrifice isn't a
change to gameplay it's not even
addition to any gameplay systems it's
simply a story around 100 minutes long
which embraces warframe and it's law and
gives its audience a cinematic
experience to cherish warframe has many
quests like the sacrifice the war within
and the second dream which are solely
here to reward players who want to know
more about the lore of warframe in a
world where games are dumbing down for
ease of access warframe says no let's
add emotion story and some complexity
and for that reason alone the sacrifice
expansion deserves to be on this list
warframe the sacrifice is going through
Sony certification as I'm writing this
but it's been guaranteed to be available
before July the 7th 2018 oh and if you
enter the code old friends o LD f RI en
D on warframe comm / promo code you'll
get a free Oricon tea set a new
decoration for your orbiter and a 3-day
affinity booster what a world we live in
a free tea set there we have it 10 more
games you can download and play for free
on your ps4 in the future we will have a
realm royale and dauntless to look
forward to and as soon as we know any
more about those games I'll be back with
another video I'm Arden from PlayStation
granade it's been an absolute pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]